こんにちは、Katie Besladoと申します。
IBMクオンタムのストラテジー担当ディレクターです。
アプリケーション研究も担当しています。今日は
量子コンピューティングに関するよくある誤解を
できるだけ多く、60秒で解消したいと思います。
量子コンピューターは本物で、実在します。
IBMクラウド上にデバイスがあり、誰でもアクセスできます。
はい、でも特定のことに限ってです。得意なのは
宇宙の仕組みで使われるような、超複雑な計算です。
ただし、スプレッドシートやメールであれば
普通のPCをお使いください。
理論上はそうですが、
しばらく先の話です。それができるほど優れたコンピューターはまだ存在しません。
当面の間は、着実に進歩しています。
そして、そこに到達したとき、私たちは情報の守り方を
大きく変えることになるでしょう。
それは完全に間違いです。量子コンピューターは
根本的に異なるものであり、
自然の法則を使って情報を処理します。
現在のAIは従来のクラシカルなデバイスで動いていますが、
将来は両者が連携すると考えています。
そうではありません。私たちには充実したエコシステムがあります。
スタートアップ、大学、国立研究所、産業パートナーが
毎日私たちのデバイスを活用しています。
いいえ、「量子インスパイアード」は
長い歴史があり、クラシカルなデバイスで動くものです。
それでは量子コンピューティングの真の可能性は実現できません。
本当の量子コンピューティングを求めるなら、本物の量子
コンピューターで行う必要があります。